hello good evening I always look forward
to attend the glamour Awards and because
it's the perfect hunting ground for me
to find mrs. MERS and where's Don French
I'm after her tonight and the little
enough about me in my future wife and
I'm here tonight to present this year's
glamour TV personality award I've been a
massive fan of this beautiful woman ever
since she presented MTV's Total Request
Live and as a teenage boy of his own VHS
player it meant I could disappear in my
bedroom for hours sometimes days and to
some she's the face of BBC smash hit
prize island yes to others she's the
rock of the heart so is the rock of the
heart not one but two of TV's biggest
popular fact that the format sorry the
voice and of course Big Brother
both of which she hosts brilliantly year
in year and never once sending the wrong
contestant home which I strongly advise
not to do and she's genuinely one of the
most down so people were ever going to
meet and on top of that he's intelligent
she's funny she's charismatic and she's
married to the second highest member of
busted ladies and gentlemen please
welcome your glamour TV personally award
goes to Miss Emma Willis and Ollie do I
still make you speech I just got an
award from the bold quite lovely right
and I'm not very good at speeches and
I've sat there literally all evening
going I thought my gonna say well I'm
gonna say I don't ought to say everybody
comes up and they say such heartfelt
stuff and and I don't get out very often
and I've had to to Keeler's and I feel a
little bit tipsy and so
so thank you to Joe where are you say
well I see another short-haired woman in
the room which is amazing and to glamour
readers last night I spent most of the
evening apologizing for the word [ __ ]
and through highs it's free rain so
[ __ ] thank you very much and I've had
lovely things so far I'm going to get
really pissed and it's J hub still here
yeah hey Lia tell my sister I had the
best time with Jennifer in the last year
on the voice and sorry I go in ordered
wages and but thank you thank you to all
the fantastic women in light my life so
many amazing women in the room and I'm
I'm looking for Dawn French where are
you I love you I love you so much and I
love you so much
I've got a room and you are very welcome
to clear down there - Rochelle Humes -
Giovanna Fletcher - all the amazing
people in my life to make some death and
to my amazing husband who is the best
member of busted thank you very much and
have a wonderful evening
and I'm going to go and get pissed
[Applause]